can we also talk about this couple Miley
Cyrus and Liam Hemsworth they finally
made their Hollywood debut as husband
and wife on Saturday we wait forever for
this I love them so much and I was there
for all of it as the newlyweds stepped
out for Liam's big honor
[Music]
it's the best it's the best it's um you
know I feel so lucky to be with someone
like her and very very very lucky 36
days down and Williams love in that
married life my Lila her man have zone
moment on the carpet who posted this
sweet pic captioned date night help and
ready to party with the mister the
couple had good reason to celebrate Liam
was honored with the Excellence in Film
Award at the g'day USA Los Angeles gala
on Saturday and couldn't help but gush
about his soul mate thank you to my
beautiful wife I get kind of embarrassed
about getting Awards for for acting I
don't know because I feel already so so
privileged to do something that I love
so much Liam's buddy Vince Vaughn
presented him with the award and Vince
took advantage of the moment to get
something off his chest I wasn't invited
to the wedding
I don't know that may or may not have
happen I don't know I wasn't invited
with I guess I would be yeah that's my
Lee flashing her ring finger but back to
the wedding
it's okay Vince I wasn't invited either
still I had to give the newlyweds a
little something my gift to you
it is a wedding gift well who are these
people this is oh it's me it's me my
wife that's right show up on Miley's
Instagram I'm hoping
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]